Голосування щодо імплементації Газової директиви ЄС
викликало в Бундестазі жваву дискусію.
Основне питання полягало в тому, чи буде влада Німеччини
робити виняток для газопроводу "Північний потік-2".
Ідеться, зокрема, про вимогу про поділ активів -
так званий анбандлінг. Найактивніше
проти законопроекту виступали німецькі Зелені.
- Велика коаліція робить крок назад і намагається
схитрувати, розмиваючи формулювання
про 23 травня цього року як про дедлайн
для завершення газопроводу, після якого діє вимога
про анбандлінг для газопроводів із третіх країн.
Цим вони відкривають усі двері для "Північного потоку-2",
тому що з наданням права виключення -
а його точно дадуть, - будівництво цього
непотрібного газогону закінчать згідно з планом.
Це просто скандал!
Депутатка від Зелених має на увазі ось таку зміну
в законопроєкті: вимогу про завершення
газопроводу до 23 травня цього року, що раніше
було однією з умов непотрапляння під дію закону,
перемістили чомусь у преамбулу. У спеціальному
пресрелізі від міністерства економіки і енергетики ФРН
стверджується, що це лише формальність
і жодних наслідків це не матиме.
Ну а як німецький закон вплине на "Північний потік-2"?
- Поки незрозуміло, якою мірою рішення Бундестагу
змінить або не змінить умови введення
в експлуатацію "Північного потоку-2".
Судячи з заяви міністерства економіки і енергетики ФРН,
"Газпрому", можливо, все-таки доведеться продати
щонайменше 12-кілометрову ділянку труби,
що проходить територіальними водами Німеччини.
У німецькій правлячій коаліції вважають, що
питання про застосування положень закону
до "Північного потоку-2" має вирішити
Федеральне агентство з мереж.
- Що стосується "Північного потоку-2", насамперед
мають бути взяті до уваги всі обставини
цього проєкту. Такий інфраструктурний проєкт
неможливо здійснити за одну ніч. Це займає роки,
і реагувати в цьому випадку повинні регулюючі органи.
У компанії Nord Stream-2 коментувати
рішення Бундестагу відмовилися, проте відзначили,
що вже звернулися до суду ЄС із вимогою
про незастосування до "Північного потоку-2"
газової директиви Євросоюзу.
У німецькому Федеральному агентстві з мереж
також відмовилися дати коментарі, пославшись
на те, що за законопроєкт ще має проголосувати
палата земель - Бундесрат. В уряді розраховують,
що імплементація європейських норм у Німеччині
завершиться до кінця цього року.